[Music]
you know rolling stone is uh not exactly
known for its journalistic integrity
this is after all the outlet that
published a rape hoax and uh once put
the boston bomber on its cover
now so i wasn't expecting exactly fair
or objective treatment when i found out
that they had wrote written about my
film what is a woman
and it's clear in the first sentence of
their piece that there is no pretense of
actual journalism here the author of the
piece moises mendes writes quote
for years right-wing commentator daily
wire host and all-around provocateur
matt walsh has used his platform to go
after trans people so it's not
surprising that this essentialist
ideology has become the centerpiece of
his new documentary what is a woman now
i take exception to this on a number of
levels first of all
i am not a provocateur i think i'm a
pretty decent provocateur so of course
these are you know ideal cultural
conditions for being a provocateur it's
a bit of a bull market for for uh
provoking considering you can provoke by
simply asking people to define words
they're using
it'd be a lot more difficult to be a
provocateur in a sane society i realize
that
um
that's not a challenge i have to deal
with though and you can't hold that
against me i'm just playing the hand i
was dealt here
anyway the real motive behind this
rolling stone piece becomes immediately
obvious the outlet
would seem to be at first sort of
breaking ranks with their corporate
media counterparts by actually
acknowledging that my film exists even
if only to dump on it
so why take this risk why risk giving me
more publicity
part of the reason is that nobody reads
rolling stone or even knows that it
still exists so the publicity factor is
negligible i'm sure that was that sort
of factored into their decision the
other reason is that they want to
pressure social media platforms to ban
me
going back to the article it says
now the daily wire has bought ads on
major social media platforms like tick
tock facebook and instagram to promote
the film and so far even though the
documentary seems to violate tick tock
and meta's policies against hate speech
though the platforms prohibit
dehumanizing mocking and or hateful
speech about transgender people the ads
have been allowed to stay
okay so this film is hate speech
it dehumanizes and mocks
don't just take rolling stone's word for
it they also spoke to glad
the activist the gay activist
organization and glad agrees quote
national lgbtq organization glad feels
that it's contradictory for these
platforms to allow these sorts of ads
especially during a time when they claim
to be uplifting and highlighting queer
content
social media companies are in the midst
of honoring pride month by loudly
sharing how they support lgbtq people
while simultaneously profiting off of
ads for a video project that is built
off of lies and misinformation about our
community these platforms can and must
do more to take action and enforce their
own rules regarding content that
violates their own standards of accuracy
and
safety oh it's unsafe content remember
red flag
this is quite a rap sheet they've
compiled for my film the movie is
hateful
dehumanizing
built off of lies and misinformation
it's so bad that we shouldn't be allowed
to advertise it on any major social
media platform
the writer moises uh must have you know
he must have really watched the movie
closely and thought long and hard about
it before arriving at these damning
conclusions i mean these are some
serious indictments
i can't imagine the research that moses
must have poured into this
his editors also must have sat down and
really watched the film carefully and
you know if they're going to publish
something like this they sat down they
watched it
did a lot of research i assume
well maybe not see we we sent screeners
to rolling stone because we thought they
might be interested in writing about the
film turns out they were you know they
were interested in writing about it but
our mistake wasn't thinking that they
might want to watch the film
before writing about it
though moises mendes and his editor
elizabeth garber paul apparently didn't
realize this we could actually see
how much of the film was viewed on each
individual screener that we send out
which means that we can see clear as day
that the editor elizabeth garber paul um
she watched a whole 11 percent of the
movie before publishing this piece
and the author i mean the guy who
actually wrote this searing indictment
of what is a woman calling it
transphobic hateful misinformation etc
he watched exactly
zero percent of the movie
we can see that you see it right there
zero percent
he didn't watch one second of it before
offering his review of the work
moises mendes he's like a food critic
who walks by a restaurant
doesn't even go in glances through the
window
and then writes a detailed review
panning the food
now you might think that rolling stone
was aware that we would know they didn't
watch the film before reviewing it and
that perhaps they just didn't care you
know maybe they were
defiantly flaunting their own
close-mindedness
but that theory is contradicted by the
fact that moses locked down his twitter
account within three minutes of me
publishing the screenshot showing that
he didn't watch the movie
rolling stone soon followed suit by
putting the article behind their paywall
they clearly weren't planning on getting
called out and didn't think they would
be
that's that's a theme consistent with
what you find in the movie itself if you
were to actually you know watch it
people on the left aren't prepared to be
held accountable
and that's
somewhat understandable to be fair in
their privileged bubble
there is no accountability
they're not familiar with the concept
they don't know how to react when it
happens
now i'm not naive i know that nobody at
rolling stone is engaging in any
self-reflection today
i'm sure moises mendes did not even take
a second to pause and ask himself wait
am i nothing but a half-witted
propagandist
is that what i've become
he's not thinking about that
instead he's no doubt hiding behind his
locked account crying that all the scary
right-wingers are being mean to him
yet even if we cannot get these people
to ever look in the mirror
and see themselves for who and what they
are
we can at least see them more clearly
and we can know that they must never be
taken seriously
nothing they say means anything
they are not interested in truth or
accuracy or anything related to it
so we shouldn't be interested in
anything that they ever say
about anything
instead we should say to moises mendez
and all the moises mendez's of the world
you are all
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content